hi I'm Wilmot Allen I'm attending the
World Economic Forum Amina and eurasia
here in Istanbul Turkey in 2012 and I am
excited to know that there are many
stakeholders invested in finding
solutions to youth unemployment here I
just want to highlight two I think very
important ideas that I've heard over the
last couple of days first of all through
Twitter in a session on brainstorming on
solutions to youth unemployment very
simple yet profound the most important
job for young people right now it's
going to be their first job and I think
there are innovative efforts to be made
to take that on I want to highlight one
which is an initiative of the Global
Agenda councils here the World Economic
Forum and IFC attend youth program which
will enlist a thousand companies to hire
ten youth train them and hopefully
employ them full-time and permanent
roles and I think it's so important that
this this action of finding young people
work is acted upon very quickly to
restore confidence to restore trust
between young people and institutions
and most of all to find ways to
jumpstart our economy and new ways
innovative ways it and that will forge
new paths of entrepreneurship